resserrer sur plusieurs jours
fait croire à des autorités
intervenir.
- Vestiges ordonnés d'une nuit
sans violence dans un centre-
ville toujours paralysé par
des résidents temporaires
déterminés àe pense que
les cammionneurs vont rester ici
ue ça ne bougera pas et
qu'il n'y aura pas d'action
du gouvernement.
que le jour 1. Jour 1 pour
le reste du Canada
et des Québécois.
- Freedom, freedom!
- La vaccinationtransfrontaliers
est devenue un catalyseur.
nifestants réclament
la fin du masque, la fin
du code vaccinal, la fin de
et depuis 48 heures, ils ont
le sentiment d'avoir l'ore
du gouvernement.
LUC BERTHOLD, député, PCC
Mégant
- Et ces gents-ltannés. comprenc
maintenant faire en sorte quelet
un peu d'espoir.
- Àdelà de la fatigue,
c'est encore la science
qui doit primer.
DOMINIC LeBLANC, ministre des
- Ce n'est pas un rassemblement
de cammionneurs à Ottaw
constitue un avis scientifique
au gouvernement.
(klaxons)
- Rien pour calmer l'ardeur de
ponctuer de leurs klaxons
la reprise des travaux
parlementaires demain.
(klaxons)
Une peparticulièrement
désagréable pour les habitants
du secteur dont la patience
MATHIEU FLEURY, conseiller
pal, Ville d'Ottawa
- C'est sans cesse le bruit,
c'est sans cesse l'intimid
contactent, nous partageantqu'ir
de sortir de la maison puis dans
la maison, ce n'e bruit
des camions.
- Combien de temps la capitale
peut se permettre d'être
paralysée? Personne n'ose, pour
l'instant, offrir de réponse.
Ici Daniel Thibault, Radio-CanO